listen
hey everybody this is gonna be my season
7 video just ranking all of the episodes
I feel like everybody's probably gonna
disagree on most of the order but I
think we could all agree that it was
probably episode 6 that was the weakest
all season long but I'm totally
expecting everybody else to argue what
the best was where everything fell in
the middle in general there were a lot
of great storylines mixed with a lot of
weak storylines so some of my pickled up
and down the list a little bit and I
wouldn't be surprised if I changed my
mind a little bit on the placement of
some of these like for instance the
finale had a lot of great mythology
payoffs but I felt like it was shackled
by that Winterfell storyline that just
pulled it down otherwise it would have
been higher in my list but if you're new
to the channel I'll be doing bonus
videos till next season comes obviously
that might be a long time so I'll try to
explain what the video schedule is gonna
be at the end of this as well as
giveaway stuff but obviously it's
starting with number 7 Pig episode 6
beyond the wall obviously we knew that
this was a terrible plan in a series of
terrible Tyrion plans so they already
had a bad reason for going north of the
wall we're gonna get proved for Cersei
even though we know she's probably not
gonna believe this and there's probably
better ways to show her that there's a
threat in the north but if you could get
past all that they had that crazy action
scene at the end they put it in the
trailer and then we got Daenerys
fighting the army of the Dead who just
this great site a preview of what it's
probably going to look like during
season 8 when she and Jon Snow are tag
teaming the night king but that's what
this episode comes down to the whole
reason that it exists is for the night
King to get a dragon so you may have
forgotten about it they talked about it
a couple seasons ago but when George R
Martin was starting to pull back on the
amount of time he was spending with the
series he actually wrote episodes for a
couple seasons he had to stop doing that
so that he could finish winds of winter
which is still a work in progress but
because they knew that the series would
end way before the books ever ended Dan
and Dave met with him he explained the
ending of Game of Thrones to them so
they got a road map of things that they
needed to do they needed to do the Tower
of joy reveal the night King needed to
get a dragon when we got to the finale
they even said we've been building to
this moment for so many seasons meaning
that George our Martin probably told
them Knight King brings the
down using one of the Dragons so they
had all these big character twists like
Jon Snow Daenerys coming together they
knew they had to do but all the stuff in
between they didn't so that's where they
started to make up things so I think
I've said it in the past where I think
Dan and Dave are great at adapting Game
of Thrones that's why all the characters
the first couple of seasons are so
strong because right up until about
season four they're straight-up adapting
the books but you get to season five
season six they start to go off-book
they have to start making things up for
the characters and coming up with
storylines that bear no resemblance to
what George R Martin is doing and that's
where you get to your Dumber version of
Littlefinger that's where you get to
your Dumber version of Tyrion characters
that are normally supposed to be the
smartest people on the chessboard
so episode six is a casualty of them
knowing the signpost they had to hit but
having absolutely no idea how to get
there well you know we'll do a Dirty
Dozen episode north of the wall how do
we get him up there Magnificent Seven
and then there were just a lot of the
character moments that I feel like could
have been a lot better they spent most
of those early walk and talks recapping
what had happened for each of the
characters like Gendry all of his
dialogue was meant to tell you hey
remember when Gendry got taken by
Melisandre the hound and torment was
probably the best thing to come out of
that when he starts talking about
Brienne of Tarth
Breanna freakin Tarth you just had to
mention her so there was a lot of good
stuff in there but I feel like you know
most people watch the episode and they
sort of brushed over all that because
they knew this big night King twist was
coming him turning vissarion that was
what the episode was predicated on the
fact that you would care about the
dragon dying so next on the list is the
finale and not because it's a bad
episode but just because I feel like it
was pulled down like I said by the
Winterfell plotline which even though it
made sense they cut so many scenes out
because they're addicted to surprises
Game of Thrones is addicted to that
twist where Sansa turns and accuses the
Littlefinger and you get that surprise
that was what all those scenes all
season long were about like you knew
that Arya and Sansa wouldn't be at each
other's throats there's no way that Arya
so much of a psychopath that she would
kill her sister and wear her face around
as she implied during episode six yet
the actor that played bran said this
Sansa came to him in a deleted scene
from the finale where she
asked him about the truth of
Littlefinger he explained everything and
that's the moment she realized that they
were being played and that's when Ari
and Santos stopped being at each other's
throats so there was this big thing all
season long where people thought they're
both playing him this whole time no it
was not an act they genuinely hated each
other all season long so I feel like
that was largely contrived and it's just
a function of this big twist at the end
so like I said addicted to surprise so
that's why the finale gets knocked down
a couple notches because there was a lot
of good stuff in the episode - I feel
like the mythology payoffs we finally
got the truth of Rhaegar and Lyanna I
know there's still a lot of debate about
how that's gonna go down in the books
I'm expecting a few minor changes but
like I said in that hotel room they got
all the big signposts from George RR
Martin's so he told them about the Tower
of joy in what was going on with Lyanna
stark and rhaegar so undead dragon
bringing down the wall great payoff we
knew it was all coming at some point
like I said it was one of the signposts
that George our Martin told them about
that they needed to hit so it was a
really strong ending and generally like
the rest of the episodes on my list are
pretty close together like there was no
one episode it was so much better than
the others with a few exceptions me you
know maybe my number one pick I felt
like it was a lot stronger than the
other episodes but still working our way
down number 5 episode 2 storm born in
one of the reasons why I love this
episode so much but it's a little bit
lower in my list is because it tied up
the sand snake plot in the most
satisfying way I felt like they could
have done it because there's still so
many hanging threads what's going on
with the forces in Dorne they had an
army they weren't all on those boats
they were going to pick them up
when they were taken out by your on so
the funny thing here and the fandoms
kind of picked up on this is that the
show just wants you to forget about door
and they're like okay we didn't really
do this the best way we could have so
we're just gonna push it off to the side
and hope that nobody ever mentions it
again so it's a bit of a joke now but I
feel like that big battle at the end of
the episode was probably one of the best
executions they had all season long
executed as in how they did it and
execution as Euron literally executed
all those people most of it I was fine
with I think some people were just
worried that they were spending so much
time on minor characters when they could
be spending it on the major characters
and I will explain
little bit about the whole seven
episodes six episodes
there's a lot of confusion about why
there are more episodes but once you
understand you'll see that they're not
wasting time in the way that you think
that they're wasting time but my next
pick was number four the premiere
episode I feel like it was a fairly
strong premiere episode but again that
Winterfell plot and all that
manufactured drama with Jon Snow and
Sansa I feel like they want to keep that
Sansa storyline as relevant as possible
because the stark children are big
characters and that's how the series
started they build it as Starks versus
Lannisters
so however interesting you find the
other ancillary stark children the show
feels obligated to include them in a big
big way so they had to create a
storyline for Winterfell this season
that I am almost absolutely certain you
won't see in the books like everybody
will get up to Winterfell eventually
that's where Jon Snow and Daenerys are
headed now so that's probably what will
happen in the books but the way that
everybody gets there will be very very
different but I just absolutely loved
everything they did at Dragonstone this
season it was probably my favorite said
my number three pick was episode 5 east
watch so a lot of fanservice in this
episode Gendry came back the like hey
remembering andrea is a thing and he has
a hammer that looks just like Roberts
but there were so many great mythology
payoffs one of the best moments all
season long was Jon Snow meeting the
dragons like I said another big signpost
that George R Martin told them they had
to hit in what it means once he comes
together with Daenerys and the biggest
part of that is that he is blood of the
dragon so the Dragons recognize his
blood and it just wound up being this
amazing moment with an amazing sound
score if you had five seconds to explain
to someone what this season was all
about you could just show them this
picture right here or you could show
them a picture of the night king riding
Viserion but this was also one of those
episodes where they started to
course-correct on bad Tyrion moments and
you got some good Tyrion moments because
he had that scene with Jamie his scenes
with his family were the best scenes
that he had all season long and there
were only a couple which is why when we
got to that Cersei moment in the finale
everyone was like oh my god this is so
great what happened to Tyrion he's a
great character where's he been all
season the number two pick was episode
three Queens Justice tell
circe it was me I feel like the Queen of
thorns went out like such a boss that
any other problems you had with the
episode you just remember that that's
the thing people walk away with but I do
think that people unfairly ding the
episode because of the way they teased a
big battle and then they just cut right
to the end of it like nope
this isn't gonna be the big battle
episode we're saving that for next
week's episode feels a fire and we're
saving that for episode 6 so if anything
it was a great character episode and I
feel like people were just down on it
because the action wasn't what they
expected so as you probably guess my
favorite episode of the season at least
right now is still episode 4 which I'm
still gonna call field of fire I'm a
little upset that the producers called
it the loot train battle that's like the
lamest name that you could give to it
but I feel like it was a great payoff
you finally got the big battle you got
to see the Dothraki just unload on
Lannisters and you got a lot of great
character moments with Bronn and Jamie
so it just proof that episode quality
isn't necessarily the same as episode
length so people tend to think that
longer episodes are better because they
include more stuff that's not always the
case as the finale proves because they
had to spend all the time on the
Winterfell plot imagine how much
stronger the episode would have been if
you didn't even have to deal with that
but because season 8 is only six
episodes long and they're all converging
on Winterfell the army of the Dead is
headed in that direction Daenerys is
headed in that direction with her
dragons and her army they're making it
seem like almost every single episode of
season 8 will be like episode 4
regardless of how long they are there's
a lot of theories about them being
feature-length episodes but all-in-all I
feel like it was a strong season maybe
not quite as strong as season 6 it was
really hampered by the fact that they
were trying to skip over as much story
as possible so let me know in the
comments what you think the worst
episode of the season was and what the
best episode was but just to clarify on
episode count so what we found out in
the last couple of months is that Game
of Thrones is ending with a specific
episode count you know the six episodes
in season eight the seven in this season
because Jan and Dave are pretty much
done with the series like they're like
okay we don't want to do this anymore we
want to move on to our next show which
people are already really upset about
that Confederate TV show
HBO on the other side of things is like
please make more Game of Thrones make 10
more seasons of Game of Thrones we'll
pay every dollar you need to make it
happen but the producers are like nope
we're done with it we're gonna wrap this
up with a couple more episodes and
that's the end of it we don't want to
deal with Game of Thrones anymore so if
you're like most of the logic problems
this season
in the character moments that didn't
quite work or just due to that them
trying to speed this along through the
last bit of the story but just a
reminder if you're worried about the
quality of Season 8
George R Martin already told them what
the ending of the story was and we know
that they're great at adapting George RR
Martin's material so season 8 is mostly
George RR Martin's season of Game of
Thrones it's the finale that he
envisioned for dream of spring so
whatever your thoughts on season 7 were
whether you loved it whether you hated
it I feel like season 8 will actually be
much stronger despite being fewer
episodes but what'll happen is is I have
a tearing video that I'm gonna do
tomorrow then I'll do another Q&A video
for season 8 stuff on Tuesday and then
after that what'll probably happen is is
they'll be Game of Thrones every Sunday
and then a couple times during the week
for the rest of the year and then just
depending on what everyone wants to talk
about we can adjust the schedule
starting it early next year but for the
most part there'll be at least a couple
Game of Thrones videos per week there's
a new round of that HBO now giveaway all
you have to do to enter just be a
subscriber or leave a comment on this
video I'll announce the winner when I
post my Tyrion video tomorrow you can
click here for my season 8 predictions
and you can click here to learn all
about Aegon Targaryen and the different
egg ons of the TV show in the books
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight